-Welcome back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good to be here, buddy.
-Always great to see you.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-Got to see you with one
of the sweetest women in
the world, Kelly Clarkson,
right there.
She´s an adviser this year.
You´re saying no.
Maybe not.
-She used to be a friend,
but now she´s competition.
-Oh, I see.
-Yeah.
-So once anybody joins the realm
of "The Voice," a history
of friendship
goes out the window.
-Yeah, because we had
actually started filming
the blind auditions
for season 14.
-Got it.
-So we´re in competition mode
right now.
-Because she´ll be a judge
in season 14.
-That´s right.
-That´s interesting.
So no matter what
your history is, they´re
just dead to you immediately.
-Enemy, yep.
-Wow.
Well, again, this is why
you´re so successful.
-That´s right!
-Because other judges
let things like
a heart get in their way.
-That´s -- Can´t do it.
-You can´t do it.
-Can´t do it, man.
I didn´t sign on to lose.
-That´s right.
-You -- but...
-They hired me to win the show.
-You --
Just to speak to your history,
You guys have done a
duet together, you and Kelly.
-We´ve done a duet together
on a Christmas album,
and then we´ve done another duet
together live a bunch of times,
which is actually a hit
that she had with Jason Aldean.
-Uh-huh.
And do you enjoy --
So, you go out
and you sing with Kelly?
Is it very loose when you do
something like that?
Do you get nervous when you´re
singing on somebody else´s show?
-[ Sighs ] I get nervous
when I sing with Kelly.
I mean, look --
I can do --
I can sing a little bit.
-Yeah.
-But Kelly --
-That´s what everyone here says.
-But --
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
So Kelly and I, we´ve have known
each other for every bit
of ten years,
and we´ve been great
friends it´s --
Oh, my God, the stories
I could tell, but --
She used to come to my shows
back in the day
every now and then,
and hang out
and that´s actually --
That´s another story.
Never mind.
She used to come hang out
at my shows
and she had this hit song
at the time with Jason Aldean
called "Don´t You Want
to Stay Here a Little While."
And... at some point
it was like, "Hey,
you´re coming to my shows.
You got this --
How about I work up
that song with my band?
You´re here anyway goofing off,
getting drunk.
[ Laughter ]
You come out in the middle
of my show and nobody knows
you´re here,
and it´ll be huge."
And so we did that,
and she came out.
And I remember the first time
she ever did it,
she came out and the crowd --
It erupted.
"It´s Kelly Clarkson.
-Sure.
-Oh, my God.
We only paid to see Blake.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-We got our money´s worth now,"
you know what I´m saying?
So, anyway, it was incredible
and then she came again.
It happened, like,
three times at my shows,
and I remember every night after
it was over I would go backstage
and hanging out and we´re
all partying and having fun
and be like, you know,
"What did you think?
I mean, that was unbelievable."
And every time
she would be like,
"Eh, that was pretty cool."
And I´m, like, "What?
There was -- All these people
freaked out."
And so then she had a show.
This was a long --
this is way longer
than you thought.
-No, but this is nice payoff.
I´m excited.
-So then she had a show in L.A.
and she called and said,
"Hey, I want you to come do
that song at my show this time."
And I owed her one.
-Sure.
-So I went.
-Technically you owed her three,
I think.
-No, that´s --
Please don´t hear that,
Kelly.
And so I went out and did
the song with her that night
and after the show I said,
you know, "Oh, my God,
that was so cool, man.
What did you think?"
And the same thing it´s, like,
"Well, it was pretty good."
[ Laughter ]
And I remember, I go,
"What -- What in the hell?"
Like, what --
I thought --
I thought I was hitting
the notes I was singing.
-Yeah.
-I know I was singing on pitch,
damn it.
[ Laughter ]
And she looked at me,
and I´ll have to clean this up,
but she said, "How come you
never sing the song
like we´re screwing?"
[ Laughter ]
And I remember thinking, "What?"
So -- And I rem--
And the reason that even came up
is ´cause now she´s a coach
on "The Voice" and I go,
"Kelly, you can´t be saying
stuff like that to these kids."
-Yeah!
Well, I´m glad.
-So...
-I´m glad you´re there
to keep her on
the straight and narrow.
-Thanks for making me tell
that story, too.
-I like that story a lot.
-I enjoyed it.
This audience, they´re...
-I would -- Now, hopefully,
singing like that is easier now
with Gwen stefani because now
you do duets with her.
You co-wrote a song.
-It works better with Gwen.
-Yeah.
-You´re, like, already there.
You don´t have to do any
of the pretend part.
-Well, I mean, you know.
[ Laughter and applause ]